I don't waste my summer at some camp I'm
Shane great for crying out loud the
Jonas Brothers are totally owning
tick-tock and we used to love this place
three years ago we were campers the trio
has longtime camp rock fans going crazy
after they recreated a scene from the
film and a tick-tock video shared on
Tuesday I don't want to waste my summer
at some camp I'm Shane great for crying
out loud
a man we used to love this place three
years ago we were campers all three
brothers co-starred in the 2008 Disney
Channel Original Movie and we are living
for the brothers impersonating
themselves in the film over a decade
later mmm this is for Kinect three
connected and you get to see uncle Brown
oh not a selling point Nick's wife
Priyanka Chopra spoke with Harper's
Bazaar this month where she admitted to
never having seen the fan favorite movie
Chopra revealed a quote I never seen
camp rock and everyone makes fun of me
about that
so maybe soon we'll have a camp rock
viewing party I bet it will be great
it's actually really annoying and the
Joe Broz clearly have a knack for a good
tik tok reenactment the video comes just
one week after they recreated an iconic
fight between Kim and khloé on Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
don't be but we'll have to wait to see
what the musicians allow us with next we
get a cameo from the jay sisters the
wives of the three brothers have made
appearances and music videos for both
their recent single what a man gotta do
and their 2019 hit sucker et spoke with
Joe's wife sophie turner about starring
and sucker just last year I'm so excited
for your new journey ahead because we
have massive TV star full-fledged movie
star and now music video star can we
please talk about the sucker music video
because in our opinion you stole the
show oh thanks that was really fun that
was another secret that I had to keep
for so long I was like building up with
secrets it was amazing that music video
I kind of when I was filming it I was
like I'm just gonna quit acting and do
music
because it's so much fun you get music
like you get drinks you get like weird
and wonderful costumes I loved it
[Music]